you know it's that time of the year
brand new year lots of hope and
excitement but always the time of year
to reflect on what's just passed and
also set up some resolutions what's
wrong with that now for me let me tell
you what i'm doing number one i really
care about what i eat these days what
you put in your body matters i don't
want to sound like a cornball but i've
really started to review
you know that just living better with
better food so i'm kind of cooling it on
what i drink i'm kind of cooling on what
i eat i've lost 22 pounds i feel like a
million bucks my energy is way up i wish
i'd started this a long time ago because
it's very easy to do try a slight change
in lifestyle just eat healthier you know
what the foods are number two really
went down the rabbit hole on crypto this
year whoa start of the year with three
percent holdings in terms of investing
in my portfolio you should think about
diversity in any portfolio how much do
you have in any one sector
never more than five percent in any one
position never more than twenty percent
any one sector so in crypto i could go
all the way to twenty percent and right
now i started the year last year 2021 at
three percent said that i'd get to seven
you know kind of slowly grooving into it
a lot of different positions not just
bitcoin not just ethereum all kinds of
other tokens but all of it together now
went past seven percent it's over ten
so i could go up to twenty percent maybe
i will in 2022. and then of course i
want to do a big shout out for josh and
i talking about money goals this is a
very cool thing we're going to be doing
every week it's the live orama which i
really love we'll be on together we'll
be talking about money my favorite topic
no question about it so check us out
this coming wednesday three o'clock new
york
live
okay i don't even know where to begin so
essentially we've got this latest poll
from cnbc and change research saying
that 60 of respondents disapprove of
president biden's handling of the
economy four and a half million people
decided to quit their jobs back in
november where are they going
walk us through how you see january
panning out because we just heard from
will talking about the fangs all in the
red yesterday
it's rather interesting the poll results
are quite a surprise to everybody hadley
you're right about that probably one of
the problems this is kind of a unique
situation that would have never guessed
in the outcome
so much
stimulus you know families getting six
hundred dollars a month and if you're
working in a high-risk job
let's say you're working in a restaurant
or in a place where there's a lot of
public on a
street car or you know on a subway or
whatever where you're you're
encountering a lot of people that's now
considered given that we're going into
almost a third year of pandemic
a high-risk position you'd rather just
not do it and i think the millions of
really by those numbers because
essentially one of the numbers was 38
percent of americans um blame the
president for rising prices and the last
time you and i spoke we were talking
about inflation and you said it i mean
people are pissed about inflation can we
really be surprised that that
disapproval rating is so high
well it's rather remarkable situation
inflation because if you look at
services there's not a lot of inflation
in services if you look at goods
particularly food and energy there's
incredible inflation double digit 12 to
19 percent and so when you go to the
grocery store and buy bread that's up 20
percent or meat or chicken or fish
whatever it is yeah it's very painful
and a lot of that was assumed to be a
lot to do with the broken supply chain
and yes some of it is is that but
there's real inflation now but look the
stimulus was insane in terms of just
dollar amounts trillions of dollars
trillions and trillions over 24 month
period why wouldn't you think inflation
would come and now it's going to haunt
this president in the midterms that
you're only months away and you know i
don't care what incumbent you are
midterms you definitely lose seats but
in this case it looks like it's going to
be devastating
for the for the democratic party and
frankly because buildback better bill is
dead uh in in some ways for the market
you know
political aspirations set aside there's
total gridlock in washington now
there'll be no more policy which is a
relief at this point and i think that
really bodes for better equity prices
and better markets gridlock in
washington is a great thing and we've
got it now for the rest of the byte
administration nothing else will get
done question for you on the on the
equity side of things what looks
attractive to you at this point because
as they say over the last 24 hours we
saw all the things in the red yeah i
mean look there's been some corrections
and you know and volatility and i expect
we'll get more i mean the best way to
look at this is to say okay
earnings potential for 2022 is up about
eight percent add one percent in
dividend yield and the market's going to
give you on an index basis about nine
percent that's not a bad outcome it's
not going to be 20 plus percent in
previous years but nine percent versus
fixed income which is basically 20 basis
points for savings accounts is not a bad
outcome which is why most people are
very constructive and remain long
equities now energy had a great run i
don't think it's going to perform as
well this year but overall tech which
has been volatile still looks very
promising because it's a productivity
tool and at the end of the day the
consumer looks immensely strong so much
so that many people are willing to quit
their jobs they've got so much in
savings it's a remarkable situation
hadley it kind of reminds me of the late
50s early 60s the american economy is
going to print i think in q1 much better
than forecasted three percent gdp growth
and yet another upside surprise i'm very
constructive on equities hi kevin it's
matt here in singapore joining in the
conversation as well uh you mentioned it
there the uh 20 plus percent uh return
that we saw when it comes to equities
like the s p 500 over the course of
2021. you don't think we'll see that
this year something more like nine
percent uh but how does the fed and of
course a return to normalizing policy
complicate the outlook for equities of
course we're anticipating that this year
we'll start to see liftoff in rates but
there's a wide divergence when it comes
to number of economists and people
thinking how fast the fed will actually
move it's true there's no question i
mean the most conservative estimates
have the fed moving three times next
year i'm not sure that's going to happen
because we have this rather remarkable
situation and it's not the same covid
that we had a year ago but it's ripping
through the u.s i'm here in florida and
we're having unbelievable outbreaks of
this
pandemic yet again but
as many people fear it's not as bad as
as the original covid but at the same
time twice as many people are getting
affected twice as fast so there is going
to be hospitalizations and as a result i
think the fed is being very cautious in
terms of moving on the economy while
they're figuring out this last to raw of
the pandemic so maybe you get another
quarter before the fed makes a move and
remember we had just under six percent
gdp growth in q4
economists brought down gdp growth in q1
that we're in right now to below three
percent and that's where the market's
having a hard time making a decision
because i think at the end of the day
we're going to do much better than three
percent
and as a result
equities still remain the choice it's
rather remarkable that to have a bull
market run this long but every bull
market has a different personality and
this one is all about longevity if you
like that video wait you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe